we have started our live streaming so if
anyone misses on the video you can use
the link
thank you we would be starting in more
two minutes
hello everyone thank you for joining
today's meeting
i would like to welcome you all today's
webinar on genomics in the virtual lab
genomics in the virtual lab is an online
program
and a unique opportunity for high school
students and beginners
this program is led by professor sona
vasudevan from georgetown university
medical center
washington dc bioclues organization
india and nishtai sri lanka and fine
biotech usa
so let me start with introduction about
us
we are a u.s based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academics and commercial collaborators
to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission
is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
we are doing this by providing training
and tools that help students and
researchers make discoveries using next
generation sequencing
data science and other bioinformatics
technologies
and tools omixlogic research-based
training programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech
and numerous academic institutions that
have participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design as
a result the omixlogic programs have
been thoroughly tested around the world
and are known to
lead to excellent outcomes for students
with minimal bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical study
majors
as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics data science
and biomedical research
my name is sunalika ray and i am the
omixlogic community manager responsible
for daily interactions with thousands of
users that are a part of a
bioinformatics community
managed by pine biotech i am honored to
have been working
with a team that collectively has
amazing experience in this
area including the other other
co-founders of the company
dr alfred truber who is
working who comes from a medical
background with expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information and one of these projects
is the establishment of the toba
bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
dr leonard brodsky is the director of
the toba bioinformatics research center
and he is an expert in bioinformatics
and biostatistics
he has numerous publications on
bioinformatics and
over the course of his career he has
developed multiple
novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical data analysis
these have been widely used in basic and
translational research in biotechnology
pharmaceutical r d
agriculture and basic research our
platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people mentioned here on the
right
julia panna who was an expert by
information
and has helped prepare many of the
materials that we would use
avi tadovsky is a computer scientist and
leads the development of the tbi
info platform that we would be using as
a part of the
course and i will also be introducing
our team members in india
in the next few slides so dr harpreet
has an expertise in the application
of statistical machine learning
techniques on biomedical data
and the development of prediction tools
and databases
and she looks after the curriculum
development bioinformatics and data
science course development
dr mohit mazumdar he's an expert by
information
with multiple publications in
peer-reviewed journals and
collaborations in
industrial academia over the past
several years he has been developing
collaborations with universities
as a mentor and project lead for omix
logic training and research fellowship
now coming back to the program genomics
in the virtual lab is a special
opportunity to learn about genomics
and big data analysis from a
world-renowned scientist and a team of
bioinformaticians
working on cutting-edge big data
challenges in biomedical research
professor sona vasudevan professor of
biochemistry
and molecular biology at the georgetown
university medical center
will present disease associated projects
that program participants can learn from
to see how genomics is used at the
intersection of data science
and biomedicine in this online program
participants will learn about the
analysis of high throughput genomics
data
and apply complex and computationally
intensive data processing steps
to large-scale public domain data
the program would include certification
for participation
as well as excellence and the
certificate of excellence would be
provided to students who would exceed
the progress expectations
and complete the online courses and
propose a novel bioinformatics project
now i would like to pass it on to ceo
pine biotech ilya brodsky over to you
india
thank you very much as america let me
share my screen
welcome everyone to today's session i'm
excited to see so many of you
joining and hopefully what we will be
able to provide you with
is a brief view of the topics that we'll
be covering
as well as introduce you to the main
program
coordinator dr sono vasudevan and some
of the other participants and partners
that we have
joining this program to talk about their
need for
research in using bioinformatics and
using data science
so my name is elia brodsky as sonalik
already mentioned i'm one of the
co-founders of pine biotech so i wanted
to kind of briefly
introduce what we do why are we
organizing this program
and where can you envision yourself
applying bioinformatics after completing
a program like this
so probably many of you have heard about
the uh genomic revolution right and so
the genomic revolution started
uh in the 20th century we're now in the
21st century so it really started in the
past
century but it didn't happen so long ago
and
over the past 50 or 60 years
there has been a tremendous growth in
the
type of sequencing data interest
in the human genome and other type of
genomic data
and really a revolution going on
using such genomic data in many
different aspects
of biotechnology agriculture and
biomedicine
and essentially what genomics often
boils down to is analysis of the genomic
code to identify
variation and that variation could lead
to
these changes in the phenotype so
essentially
the change in the genomic sequence could
lead to a change in the way that cells
tissues and organisms look and function
and those could be
diseases or they could be natural
variation
like different color of skin different
length of your eyelashes
or maybe even different height and
things like that
so what we think of typically when
we consider genomics is this idea
of finding bugs in the code right so if
those of you that are coming from an
engineering background maybe familiar
with
coding and data science having code work
perfectly is almost impossible as you're
developing that code and so oftentimes
finding that bug can really help you
understand what is going wrong with a
function
or some kind of an algorithm that you're
trying to run now where does genomics
applied especially in the area of
biomedicine
genomics is extremely important for
understanding drug metabolism
so we understand how different proteins
are able to
process different types of chemicals
and typically drugs are those chemicals
that we want to make sure that they're
metabolized
properly you can also think of genomics
and application to cancer so somatic
mutations and tumor development
inherited mutations like in sickle cell
anemia
where the adaptation to different
diseases has led to these phenotypic
changes that are now
causing some kind of a susceptibility to
disease
rare genetic diseases uh that
could be linked to repetitive elements
in our dna and also drug resistance and
obviously
now living in this pandemic we know
about genomics so much more because it's
been in the news it's been in the
media everybody knows about the
mutations the variance of concern
everybody has been hearing about this
and so it's an extremely
important domain for research but also
an application
to different areas in biomedicine in
fact today
genomics is truly in the clinic and so
you can see
here an example of a report that is
being
produced to kind of establish risk for
developing
certain types of conditions and this is
a routinely used method
in the medical field today at least in
some of the western countries and so i
think what's very important is that
genomics is moving away from just being
purely in research
and being actively used in clinical uh
in the clinical setting and we see this
um
as a very important development
primarily because the cost of sequencing
is much lower availability of reference
data is much greater and so there is
already a clear and established
relationship between specific
changes in the dna code and specific
diseases and conditions that could be
clinically categorized
but it hasn't always been like that and
even today there's an active
research also on the impact of specific
mutations
because if you consider how these
mutations occur
and how do they actually lead to
diseases
it's a complicated coordinated kind of
an effect
of multiple multiple factors so here you
can see
the significance of dna variation in
cancer where
acquired mutations germline mutations
mutations in different types of genes
and in dna repair genes all of those
come together to form
a certain level of risk after which
there could be an event that could
trigger some of those
important changes in critical genes and
ultimately lead
to what we know as unregulated tumor
growth and development
and so these types of changes
are really important for us to
understand from
the basics of genomics and the basics of
what this data could show us about these
diseases
because detecting those changes early on
and also knowing the context of specific
mutations can really help us understand
how to treat diseases that previously
were essentially untreatable
now more than just individual mutations
there are many different types of
mutations so there are many different
types of variations
like multiple nucleotide changes at the
same time
changes that accumulate in a specific
region
maybe translocation so certain regions
even
moving to another position or maybe copy
number variation right so
many different types of changes in the
dna and importantly
it's not just the human dna but also the
dna
of many different other bacteria
viruses and parasites that are important
for
the disease progression and treatment
and so i hope that in this program we'll
have an opportunity to see
how genomic data could be used to
understand many of these conditions
and how can we study genomic data so
that we understand
the important factors that are
that are essentially critical for
understanding of disease
treating disease tracking epidemics like
the epidemic that we're seeing now
or other potential epidemics that we
might see
in the future but i think the critical
part of this program
is that it will provide you with an
insight
about next generation sequencing data
how that data
is generated what does this data really
represent in terms of the technical
part of genomic data sequencing
and then we'll allow you to evaluate
some of this genomic data
using these practical data sets that we
will take
to understand where do we see just
simple variation
where can we track mutation how do we
then
categorize mutations and understand
what do these mutations really mean for
the phenotype
and so we will make sure that in this
program after you
complete the training you will be able
to understand the different terminology
of what is a nucleotide how
can we categorize different changes of
nucleotides
how do we then annotate those
nucleotides and how can we
essentially find this association with a
phenotype
including some examples of what these
phenotypes might
mean now all of this together
is really the domain of bioinformatics
because bioinformatics
combines informatics the information
technologies that allow us to
retrieve store annotate and efficiently
use
different types of information
statistics
or using statistical methods to be able
to analyze such data
and the domain where we apply this in
the
domain of life sciences or biology so
that includes biological research
biotechnology agriculture genetics and
biomedicine
and essentially because of this growth
of data the availability of data and the
need to
use this data in a meaningful way we
have developed this
omics logic training that includes
different types of
data repositories mentorship
and training and this program is one
example of such training that we offer
to be able to equip the next generation
of life science researchers clinicians
and industry professionals that will
essentially transform the way
medicine is being done the way that new
drugs are being brought to market
and the way that we can innovate early
discoveries
that will inform different types of
applications in the future
so the reason why we call this comics
logic is because
the data that we are describing here
genomic data
is just one of the omics data types that
is becoming more and more useful
and prominent in this field and so
omix logic combines different
user-friendly tools
including different methods of
statistical analysis and machine
learning
it includes the logic behind
experimental design
so that we can understand the technical
variation in the data
it gives you access to big data mining
tools that you can easily use to study
this data
and it provides also examples of how
this data could be efficiently analyzed
to spot significant changes in the
context of real world studies
and so this omics logic
program is one program that is going to
be
available on june 21st and it provides
you with a complete
road map to get started and learning
about bioinformatics and about genomics
in general so
in this program you'll be able to find
data sets explore them and visualize
them
understand research methods and get
insight and understanding potentially
leading you to an independent practice
project that you can develop in a short
period of time
so to kind of give you a little bit more
detail about
omixlogic and beyond this program that
we're discussing today what it offers
i would just briefly ask all of you to
go to our
omixlogic portal which is
learn that omicslogic.com
and so i am uh sorry posted in the
wrong chat here um okay thank you very
much
so um to kind of give you a sense of how
this program will work
and how all of this content is going to
be organized
let me briefly show you um how you can
get started today
so if you go if you could go with me to
our portal and please let me know
in the chat once you are there okay you
can put
there or yes or something you will find
uh that there's a button to log in
and you can create a free account
on here or log in with your social media
and so i want to show you briefly how
this is going to work
okay thank you brasili manali
all right thank you sonanika so please
let me know once you're in and you've
registered
okay anyone else if you already have an
account
once you log in and you're in
you can go right here to programs
and on the program page you will find
genomics in the virtual lab and so this
program right here
is going to provide you with all of the
information about today's session
and what you will learn in this program
and
after a few minutes we will hear a
little bit more
about what are the different topics and
how this is going to be
delivered so here you can see
an overview of the schedule
and some of the important tools that you
will get access to so let me
briefly tell you what are some of these
program resources
that you will be getting access to as a
part of this program
so for different parts of the program we
will
leverage omics logic resources that are
designed
to help you learn about genomics and
this includes a synchronous coursework
with theoretical material quizzes and
practical assignments
our cloud-based analytical server where
you can analyze large
genomic data and visualize results the
onyx logic code playground
when you where you can practice coding
in r in python
as well as a repository of project
examples that will guide you from data
the logic of the analysis to the
practical exercises that you can
replicate
the analysis that was described in the
publication
so first of all we will have an
asynchronous course that you can join
and
a lot of this you can actually start
looking at for free
which is an introduction to genomics if
you're absolutely new to genomics this
is the place to start
you can go to this course to understand
the applications of genomics
some of the basic terminology maybe some
refreshment of your molecular biology so
you understand what is dna
how is it translated into proteins and
things like that
and then you will also learn about how
genomic data is generated
and how you can analyze this data to
extract meaningful information from it
so to get started you actually don't
need
to know a lot of coding all you will
need to know is the logic
behind what you are trying to do so what
is the data described
and how you might potentially analyze
this data
and so that is going to be done using
the t-bioinfo server which is a big data
analysis platform
that provides you with easy to use
graphical user interface
where you just push buttons and get some
kind of a result
immediately and so on this platform you
will see
these maps logical maps of complex
analytical pipelines that will allow you
to process data
from raw format to a structured format
and once that analysis is done you will
get introduced to
important functions and tools using r
and python that will provide you with a
clear insight
about how coding is a critical component
of bioinformatics
and what you can do using these existing
packages to quickly get results
of sequence analysis and
annotation so again we
hope that this can get you started and
even before this program is launched
you can start learning about the
fundamentals of genomics
of code and analysis and the
applications of bioinformatics
about this kind of biomedical these
kinds of biomedical applications
so now to talk a little bit more about
genomics in the virtual lab which is
a an intensive program that is intended
to provide
some of the basic material and the
grounding in genomics
as well as see some of the potential
applications of genomics to biomedical
challenges
i want to describe how these programs
are going to leverage from these
asynchronous resources that i briefly
spoke about
and give you an opportunity to immerse
yourself
into this genomic data analysis
experience
that will combine interactive sessions
on zoom like we're having today
self-guided study materials that you
will have access to
and some of these practical assignments
that will include in-class assignments
but also assignments that you can do
yourself
and then present your results to your
peers and to the mentor of the program
so the program as was already mentioned
is going to be run primarily by dr
sona vasudevan she has
an extensive background with
research but also she loves teaching and
to talk a little bit more about herself
her background
and how this program is going to uh be
done
i want to pass it on to dr sona
vasudevan
from georgetown university
a co-host for her to share
yes i'm not getting the option in here
can you please check
okay there we go thank you so much
finally thank you and i'm sorry uh there
was some technical glitch
and uh that kind of leads me to uh
what uh the course is all about uh thank
you ilya
and i want to thank pine biotechnology
mohit
sonalika and others for giving me the
opportunity to actually run this course
and i'm very very excited so good
morning good afternoon good evening to
all of you
i'm sure you're all from different parts
of the world here
uh and it's an honor to have all of you
and thank you for taking the time
to be here today to listen about what
the course is all about
uh ilia has already done most of the
work for me
in terms of laying the foundation of why
bioinformatics
and informatics and data science is
extremely
important today it almost seems like you
wake up
and i'm sure all of you sleep with your
phones wake up with your phones
um look up things online so look up
things on your phone and everything else
right so
technology has moved pretty fast um in
the last
10 years or so i got into bioinformatics
about 15 years ago or even more a little
more than that
um and i have actually witnessed every
day how things have changed and where we
are today
and it seems like in the last 15 years
um
we have huge amount of data that is
accumulated
we have patient data we have sequencing
data from animals we have so much of
data so
one thing i'm sure all of you will agree
with me today is that we are drowning
in data from all different uh
walks of life right so bioinformatics
is about uh trying to figure out how to
use this data meaningfully
and right now it's as elia also
explained very clearly that the field of
medicine
and looking at diseases has completely
changed
so we all need data science to be able
to understand diseases
from sequences and so that's what i'm
doing for a living
i am a professor at georgetown
university in the department of
biochemistry as
sonalika introduced me earlier i
also direct a master's program in
the field called systems medicine i'm
not sure how many of you have actually
learned
heard about that it's a very new field
and i call this a new language
and i feel that this language
encompasses bioinformatics
and this is a language that all of us
need to learn sooner or later to be able
to converse and understand diseases
better
so the summary of that program
or what systems medicine means is one
size doesn't fit all
so two people you and me may have the
same cold
and cough and everything but the same
medication may not work in you
as well as it works in me and we are
still living in the panda beach
hopefully we'll get out of this soon um
but we all have learned one thing that
each person is different each person
reacts to
this virus differently because we're all
underlying makeup of our genome is very
very different
so how does that relate to the course
genomics in which labs so
as elia said right there are mutations
and there are variations
in your genome so the way i look at
things is if there
is a mutation in your gene it gets
personal
so any change in your gene is going to
affect
the genome in some way and it manifests
itself in diseases
i'm sure you all know that majority of
the diseases
hormonogenic diseases where a single
mutation affects
a particular gene in the human genome
that leads to diseases
there is only one mutation so you may
ask a genome is like
six feet we have billions of base pairs
and how
one single mutation is affecting the
gene
and we end up getting diseases right so
that is what this course is all about
how important genes
are to the functioning of the body and
how
single mutations in a gene lexical cell
anemia
or huntington's disease or any of those
diseases how that one single mutation
is altering the gene and manifests
itself
in diseases so the genomics in virtual
lab you all probably will see the
syllabus at some point in time
or if you have not already seen that it
is
um two weeks a course
and it starts with uh introduction to
what bioinformatics is
and what big data is and then you you
will learn a lot of different resources
that actually are reliable resources
that gives you all the information that
you need to go and understand
a protein sequence which chromosome does
this protein belong to or gene belongs
to
does it have a three-dimensional
structure
and how do you relate sequence to
functions which becomes very very
important
how are drugs designed how do we get
drugs and i'm sure in the scope with
time you all know rem deceiver came
about very quickly
and made it to the clinic so how did
that happen
so all of those things will be covered
so we have both lecture based
and also we have hands-on that goes with
it
you will learn to learn a lot of
different resources you will learn a lot
of different tools
that you can apply to any disease that
you're interested in working
and so then after the lecture and the
hands-on sessions and we'll also have
a renowned a person in the field of
bioinformatics that we have we will
invite who will actually give you
uh the importance of bioinformatics from
nih or georgetown university or george
washington university
um and who is going to tell you the
importance of bioinformatics
so from a practical aspects by the end
of the course
you're all going to know where
bioinformatics started and why
we cannot live without bioinformatics in
this age
and what is the relevance of
bioinformatics in medicine
and how do you understand diseases and
in fact
what causes those diseases is something
that you will actually learn
it's a very intense program uh but
hopefully
we'll make it fun i like fun i'm not a
serious lecturer
so it'll be fun we'll have games we will
do lots of things
we will go to your pace and uh finally
you will be amazed at
the project that you're going to come up
with um and so i'm hoping that
it'll be very fruitful and you will
learn a lot
and find biotech as uh elias showed or
mixed logic is an outstanding platform
and
in my opinion is one of the best
platforms that we have that encompasses
so many different aspects
so you're going to become budding
experts in bioinformatics
and from practical aspects it's going to
pay you a lot of money
in terms of jobs so job opportunities
are huge
for bioinformatics right now and most of
my students who just graduated from my
program
already have jobs so from a practical
aspect this is a skill sets that's going
to be very very valuable
to whatever you want to pursue uh in
your lives
so with that i will transfer it back to
ilia
and unless if i if you have any
questions or
uh if elia you want me to talk about
something else uh or cover
or any other aspects that you think that
uh
you want me to talk about well no first
of all thank you for
this overview i do want to ask if there
are
any questions uh from the participants
today if you have any questions for dr
vasudevan
you can post them in the chat and she
will have time to answer those
in just a few minutes uh also uh
somebody i wanted to ask that you
um share the link to the forum
for those that might be um
joining us from places that we want to
discover
[Music]
okay thank you so um as you're thinking
about your questions
this is a form that will help you
understand better those of you that have
joined today
we are asking that you fill this out
if you would like to receive future
information
about the program start the first
session of this program is going to be
open also to everyone
so you're welcome to invite your friends
and contacts to join the first session
which will be
discussed the whole schedule is going to
be discussed at the end of today's
session
and again if you do have any questions
feel free to post them in the chat and
we will have a time for
q a in just a few minutes now i would
like to pass it on
uh sonalika maybe you could introduce
the next
speaker thank you so much
now i would like to invite dr sugunakar
from bioclues dr suvanakar worries
presently assistant professor in lovely
professional university
india and also he is the secretary of
bioclues organization
india he has been earlier post doctoral
fellow in icmr
and also changnam national university
south korea
he has done his phd in cancer genetics
and is an expert in the same field
over to you dr sugunakar
yep thank you so much uh
i hope i'm audible to you all yes sir
you are audible
yeah uh i could
share the screen
yeah please excuse me for a couple of
minutes
yeah yeah one second aparna uh yeah we
need to make her
a co-host so just one moment okay there
we go
you i think it should be working for you
now
yeah thank you yeah it's
it's pleasure to be part of uh
this evening uh thank you ilya
thank you so now as devon
all the participants i i take this
opportunity to just brief
about uh the bio close organization
where
i take a position of high secretary
uh basically bioclues has started in the
year 2005
with an idea of bioinformatics club
offered by experimental scientists
and the and the biogas has got a mission
under mentoring outreach research
through awareness
and entrepreneurship so further
uh when we talk about bioclues it spread
across
different countries more than 40-50
countries
which we are currently working on
so talking from india australia us
and even we have started uh
other other places across the globe and
the
milestones uh we talked about the way
back in 2005
where the virtual organization was
founded uh
co-founded by dr prashan survarjala and
pradesh
raj uh in 2016 first virtual projects
conference
took off in 2007 first publication and
several conferences been organized
and it's been 16 years now
where where we have covered under
various
various points mentioned over here
in the 2009 i just tried to give some
glimpses
where 209 we started women in biology
forums started
with fulfilled society and and then we
become the isp affiliate
introduced the bird awards which are
specifically given to the
people who are uh has got expertise in
the field of bioinformatics
uh so uh to encourage uh in the
indian in the indian science science
fraternity
and also uh recognize people abroad
and to the interval we have included ikp
knowledge park
at genome valley india structured an
open access general peer review general
journal of international journal of
computational biology
and first ever toll free mentoring in
bioinformatics
in 2013 bioclass overseas phd program
a joint program with albert university
denmark
and 2004 into the 19 uh
publication we basically follow uh
publication corporatics like
life memberships and travel grants in
2009 we joined forces with
pine bio towards education programs
and then it started in the year 2020 we
started with bioinformatics for schools
and then we also started international
chapters
and regarding sustenance we use
inverted paid memberships corporate
memberships
virtual on-site conferences project
resources
and we do grants and funding yeah
please next slide and uh to give a
a brief introduction like founded by dr
prashan survazila
and the present president is
he is the director of cs ernest
and the immediate past president dr
jerome valadi
and the honda represented gps raga and
several other vice presidents and it has
been registered as
uh not not for profit organization
and adheres create to commonly sense
and there are four revenues as i
mentioned um
mentoring outreach research
enterpriseship and
approximately we have around four
thousand uh
500 plus members right now and across 40
countries it's been spread
and uh currently we do uh
mercy projects and more than 250 more
250 scientists are involved
in various projects and a lot of
collaborations that
come across different ten universities
and organizations across eight countries
and around 40 publications and over 100
conferences
have been presentations have been given
and we published in impact financial
between
1.15 to 11.836
and we do conduct five
conducted five virtual conferences and
several international meetings organized
and only official direct affiliate of
international society of computational
biology and
asian specific uh bioinformatics network
in india yeah i think
i can you can you can go ahead from this
slide yeah thank you
so nalika may start
thank you so much sir so now i would
want to dr aparna banerjee dr aparna
banerjee
is assistant professor in catholic
university of
malaysia and also the present joint
secretary in bioclues organization
india she has done a phd from the
university of badwan
india and her area of expertise is an
applied microbio
biology of extreme environments
comparative genomics
and bioinformatics over to you man thank
you so much
thank you sunadika uh thank you alia uh
thank you dr sona basudevan and dr
suguna karuvuri
so i will take the next lead to talk
about bio close
um bio clues have uh to system biology
have done a lot of system biology
workshops
in virtual mode occasionally two so
there have been three week
bioinformatics workshops scattering the
needs of scientists and the wetland
professionals a more than 1500 people
benefited
of or organization that we have made of
nearly 49 such events
eminent faculties from india and abroad
joined over there
several workshops has been organized in
columbus sri lanka
and all over the india we have rigorous
teaching program project in
collaboration with several organizations
like national university of singapore
florida university united states and in
italy
we also do certificate and honorarium at
the end of the workshops
i cannot move the map maybe you can
reshare your screen that would work i
think
okay stop sharing and that ratio okay
yes so ah as a resource by close
organization of competent core team
we have prolific workshops and several
events we have blade server
we go through mentor mentee relationship
as we as dr bury also mentioned earlier
and we have several bioclose interest
groups
so some notable projects of bioclues has
been cancer institute
chennai accessing the human smoker
population prone to lung cancer
a checkerboard analysis using ngs data
it has been also with ludhiana
university a bacteriophage genome
brosella fudge ah annotation and there
has been also the hyper project
prediction of hypothetical protein
function in humans
about the ng's expertise the studied
organism has been human cow east
bacteria
through the platform of illuminati
parent and multiplexed
the services that we offered are
mentoring graduate students in biology
and bioinformatics
annotated and curate ngs datasets
transcriptomic and genomic analysis of
ngs data that includes gene expression
analysis
variant analysis with or without
reference genome
genome diversity and coverage
distribution pathway analysis and
protein interactions
functional mapping with gene ontology
and pipeline developments
so talking about the gene uh our team
prashan surubjala and prishit pritis
bharatwaj
they have co-founded the organization 16
years back
now the court uh is formed with
president nadhari sastry
the secretary suganakar bhuri with me
being the joint secretary
the finance chair harpreet singh and
santos
with the women in biology chair with
successing and renuka surah jalla
the student chapters are done by arvind
pritchard and raksmi
sukumaran the internship chairs are v.a
sundar rajan and anil kumar
the outreach chair are by jairaman
valadi
the research chairs are by pv kishore
and hima kumari
with the mentoring chairs finally with
biswan adam dupatla and prashant surabh
allah
many of them actually today has joined
with us prashanth
dr sundar and they have all been the
driving force to bio clues
here are the mentioned honorary advisors
of bioclues 2 with the
founding board or executive members so
the
latest conference that have been
successfully organized was in weeks 2020
uh with the being the affiliates of iscb
and apb bionic
so there are some glimpses of in mix
2020 workshops that we organized
three workshops and then some glimpses
of inbix 2020 here
and finally we have also started in 2020
by informatics for school children
program and two batches have already
graduated
uh the third batch will start soon also
uh
so we focus on hands-on and home-based
learning
and we emphasis on strong stream and
curriculum product development
with a total of 12 entrancing classes
um so here
we thank you all for giving an
opportunity to talk about bio clues
and we will be happily sharing our
expertise
in this um genomics for virtual lab
program
thank you sonalika and thank you thank
you very much
and uh i wanna just uh now pause and
i see that there are several different
questions
um maybe we could address those
questions now
so first of all uh there's a question
and
uh dr vasudevan if you could please
answer these questions so
here at iqbal is asking for a basic
science person
what should be the first step to land in
the vast ocean of bioinformatics
um actually here that's uh that's
actually an outstanding question
because you know what i had to swim in
the ocean i don't know swimming
so now um having gone through a long
process i can tell you the
uh the first thing is to actually um
take this course
because that gives you a foundation of
bioinformatics and
if not this course uh because it may
seem like i'm advertising for my own
course but
uh but fine biotechnology actually has
lots of introductory courses in genomics
one genomics two
i think those will be a good start um
for
someone from basic sciences and i'm
actually trained as a basic scientist
myself
uh in fact i'm trained as a physicist
and then moved to biology and um
and i'm from your same background as
basic sciences and i think
when i was trying to get into the field
there were not that many courses or any
of these things so
it was a hard way so long story short
it's a long answer for a short question
i think any of the introductory courses
um
that's on pine biotech will be a good
start uh and of course we'll be very
happy to
guide you further if you need uh more
information
um and then the second question is for a
biochemist how can we relate
pharmacogenomics with bioinformatics
actually
um that is actually a very uh relevant
question to the times we are living in
uh with respect to pharmacogenomics
right so
pharmacogenomics is the other term for
personalized medicine precision medicine
or systems medicine
um and so uh how can we relate so
for pharmacogenomics in my opinion and
i'm sure ilya can add to that
is you need foundations of structural
biology
because at the end of the day you want
to learn how to design drugs
and then once you know how to design
drugs we can actually
use all the approved drugs that we have
today
to do some repurposing and so in my
opinion
it is and biochemistry is actually
fundamental
and prerequisite to most of the
biological processes
because you know once you have a gene
you know how biochemically it is
actually working in the cell
added to that if you add the omics part
to it i think that will be
uh very very important um i'm not sure
if
you want to add something to it i just
wanted to ask you i think
you were your background is in
structural biology right
that's right that's right so um just to
give my
path uh to where i am today i actually
started as a physicist
and then by accident uh and i'm trained
as an x-ray crystallographer
so i did a phd in extra crystallography
uh and then my postdoctoral training was
actually in
wet lab molecular biology that was my
first introduction to biology
um and then so now i'm able to then i
entered bioinformatics and now i'm able
to look back and combine structural
biology because that is helping me with
respect to
uh understanding pharmacogenomics and
how one drug
works and one just doesn't work it's all
at the end of the day
we look at biology in three dimensions
um
and so i think that's useful um
and and also maybe we can mention that
uh you know as a
biochemist uh you know
not only can you relate pharmacogenomics
and bioinformatics you can actually
participate
because i think a lot of people that
don't have that biochemistry background
they don't appreciate as much the
interaction between the structures
uh you know they might be only looking
at the sequence level but in this
program i think
uh dr vasudevan will mention the
importance of
keeping those two things in mind that's
right that's right so it will be a
a natural transition from first
principles biochemistry uh
amino acids and how they fold together
and how the structures made and
how the structure define the function so
thanks ilya for that
note um so let's see um
there is a question what's the
importance of linux platforms
in bioinformatics and do i need to learn
unix for
further studies in bioinformatics
from sulahadeen um
so um i think um as elia said in his uh
introductory i think there was a very
nice slide
where um i like the slide how you define
bioinformatics so
bioinformatics actually has different
wings so
you are a hardcore biologist or you are
a software engineer
or you are a biostatistician so they all
come together
because bioinformatics is a very
interdisciplinary field so it depends on
which
which wing you want to pick out so
i am a hardcore researcher so i have
programmers who do the programming part
for me
and i don't do programming personally
myself
so it is an interdisciplinary field so i
either whichever wing you want to choose
whether you want to choose research wing
which way you use other people to do the
programming or you can be that software
engineer
to actually um you know use so which
means linux platform is actually very
very important uh
in terms of most of the tools right now
um
but unix um ailia do you want to um
yeah i would just briefly add to that
that you know there's many
there are many limitations to user
interfaces
a simple example if you want to open a
large table
you can only open a table that big and
so
because these user interfaces want to
load everything into the ram
the more efficient way to do that is to
use
linux that has access directly to files
without
necessarily loading all the files so you
can extract information
out of a file without opening the whole
thing as we move into the field of big
data analysis that's critical because
every file is gigabytes and gigabytes
and so you just
can't operate that without huge
resources so it's a more efficient way
of doing things the other part of it is
that many tools
are designed around linux and so
simple uh settings of those tools how to
run those script
scripts how to combine scripts into
pipelines
all of that typically is done on linux
but
as sona mentioned there are many
variations of bioinformaticians and so
there are people that design the
algorithms
use the algorithms interpret the
algorithms
outputs but even generate the data for
those algorithms to use
all of those people i think need to use
bioinformatics at a certain level and so
for
this program we're going to be focused
on kind of user-friendly bioinformatics
things that you can do
on windows on mac systems you don't
necessarily need to know linux to
get all the tools that we're going to be
using here
but what you will be able to do is think
critically
about the data and the application of
these
tools to potentially research for
biomedical
challenges so there's a
there's a question about um from manali
um so you graduated from bioinformatics
um and you want to do a master's in bind
and eventually you want to do a phd in
bioinformatics which is fantastic we
really need more
trained people to help us all here but
my
personal advice to you i'm sure other
people would
can actually add um to this my personal
journey has been that
trained as a structural biologist i
actually did biology in the lab
and so i find that i'm able to operate
appreciate
more of the biology side of things
because i've been in a lab
uh if i had completely done only
sequence analysis
just using a computer i don't think i'll
be able to appreciate the biology of it
as much as i am now able to understand
it better this is my personal view
that my advice to you would be to pick a
phd where you actually do lab work
so that you can actually come up with
predictions using bioinformatics but
actually
uh you know authenticate that prediction
and validate the predictions in an
experimental setting that makes you a
full person to understand different
things that will be my advice
but of course there are other experts in
this call so
um if someone else wants to add to it um
please do and so could i just ask i
think that a lot of people are
interested in joining a master's degree
program so i know that you're a
director of a master's program could you
tell
a little bit about the program itself
and what kinds of
qualities do you look for in students
that are applying yeah thank you so much
elia for giving me the opportunity to
talk about the program so
um georgetown has the master's program
maybe i can actually
open up the website um and i'm not sure
if i can
share so um so this is
the master's program and it's a 10 month
program
um it is from start to finish um and
it actually trains you to
um all different aspects of
bioinformatics
um so it is like a layered approach so
you what background you can come from
any background that is computer
computer science or a biology or
bioinformatics or any discipline you can
enter the program
and what the program when you leave the
program you're going to have a full
flavor from start to finish different
layers of
informatics you'll learn about genomics
you learn about proteomics you learn
about microbiome
and you will learn about different
aspects of how clinicians are using
bioinformatics
um and then you will also learn how to
critically read
scientific literature and how do you
translate all of this information from
all of this data
in a clinical setting from bench to
bedsides
if i may say that and then we'll have
clinical metabolomics
and so this is a layered approach and
also
the most important part of this program
is you also get to do research
in fact this program that's how i got to
um
interact with pine biotech and they play
a significant role
as well in in helping with different
courses and as well as
you know different aspects of the
program as well
in fact there's one course that's
machine learning that ilia
actually um ran and we i want to uh
you know bring that backwards back um
and so so this is different
aspects layered and you learn about
statistics whenever you talk about data
whenever you talk about big data
you don't know whether it's
statistically significant
and we are talking about one mutation or
one variant
that we are seeing is that variant
statistically significant right so now
we are talking about lots of covert
variance
how many people have been sequenced how
many people actually have that variant
is it even significant
right so statistics is a big part of it
um
so this is a program uh that you can
you're all welcome to apply the deadline
is actually
july 1st um i'm not sure how many of you
are ready to apply but
i know most of you are probably in high
school still but this is a program to
consider or you know spread the word
around
we still have a couple of spots left for
this coming fall it starts in september
so i posted the link to the site in the
chat
anyone that is interested and i do want
to mention that
even if you scroll through you can see
genomics in the lab and so this
experience is kind of like a view into
what this program is going to be all
about and obviously you'll have access
to uh dr vasudevan here
and you can ask her questions about any
of the topics that
you might want to learn in preparation
for this program yeah so genomics is lab
that
that is pretty much where um you know
this is
this is literally in the lab uh so since
we're not going to be physically in the
lab
uh so this is what we call it the
virtual lab
um so pretty much we're doing all the
experiments in the computer instead of
the lab
uh thank you leah for giving me the
opportunity to uh
program so thank you um
so i think that now we heard about the
program
the topics and i think it will give you
a view of what a bioinformatician really
does
and how they can apply different
bioinformatics tools to a variety of
different challenges
now to transition i want to pass this on
to dr mohit mizunder who will guide us
through
the schedule of the program and the
registration
thank you india and hello everyone
let me know if you can see my screen
yeah so your screen is visible
is it visible yes sir it's visible
sorry maybe i'm not uh hearing you back
no it's okay thank you thank you so much
yeah hello everyone and thank you so
much uh idia
and uh dr professor sona
and snarlika to help and all the
bioclues members
to help us guide through the entire
program and how it will be
what are the benefits what are the
applications whom this is for
so uh genomics in the virtual lab and
this is the second version of it so we
did genomics in the virtual lab
in 2020 and we have had like really
amazing results working with
many high school students and also
undergraduate and postgraduate students
from india joined
and many other places who would want to
get
understanding of how genomics is applied
in different areas
of bioinformatics and different
areas of life science and biological
research
so uh one thing that i think
we have discussed quite a bit is the
application of
genomic research in um
in biomedical research in translational
biomedical research
but with our collaborators and the
phases of this program which i'll be
going through right now with you
all of you uh we will learn that uh that
you will learn that that genomics can be
applied to a various
uh different areas like agriculture and
many of you might have
uh have an uh bend towards working on
something like that
so we will be able to help you that
during the project phase as well
so now talking about the program so it
has
the the entire program is divided into
uh thinking of a concept of how genomics
can be
applied in basic research and as well as
how genomics can be
applied to understand healthcare
research and healthcare system and
improve the healthcare system so that
from developing a hypothesis
to be able to work on translational
research so
those are some of the objectives of this
program so introducing
uh the program from the for the
from the first week we will have the
introduction to bioinformatics session
so that will be the first session and as
if you already have
said that this session will be freely
available to
uh those who are interested in joining
the entire program
so in this session we will start with uh
the basic
of bioinformatics understand how
bioinformatics started
understands its application and will go
through a course work
of introduction to bioinformatics which
is available on the platform
that you will have access to so uh
followed by that the second day we will
be learning about protein structure and
function this will be
again with the help of uh dr sona here
uh professor sona here she will be
uh she'll be leading this session and
letting us
learn about how protein structure and
functions
are related and then we will learn about
sequence analysis
and sequence alignment and phylogenetic
analysis and how these
evolutionary and analysis helps in
evolutionary and
understanding of evolutionary distances
and then the research
that enables us to learn about the
origin
and understand all those questions that
are relevant to
today's biomedical problems so next
session we will have we will have about
mutations and 3d structures and by this
time we will learn about how we can
uh apply some of these techniques on
different data sets
so we'll we started to work on data sets
and then we have a review and activity
session
and this will be a guest session we will
have games and
we will have different kind of
activities that would be associated with
the
you know with aspects of genomics and
the guest lecture will involve
someone which is again a surprise and
which will
be which we will be announcing very soon
uh will give you an insight of how
genomics can apply
can up is being applied and is helping a
lot of people
uh with many disabilities and problems
so after the completion of the first
week and
uh that will be uh by 25th
25th june we'll be finishing the last
session and during the weekend
we'll have weekend activities and during
this time
before the end of the week we will be
providing you with the details of
the assignments and how you can
complete the assignment and what all
other elements are there
that you need to complete and we will be
sharing those details with you the data
sets
and then we will have a review session
starting next week where we will be
reviewing the video presentations
and we already have a lot of examples of
people completing these weekend
activities and i would request sunalika
if you can paste some of the links of
the participants who
completed the program last time and
completed the weekend activity video
videos so that uh so the students here
can understand that how it could be
so the second week is uh going to be
more about research so you understand
about the structure and function
how genomics is applied and with the
help of professor sona
we will have such a amazing interactive
sessions that
i can assure and guarantee you that that
because
last time it we have had an amazing
experience going through this entire
journey
learning from her learning from
different tools that she is being part
of
while developing so after that we will
be transitioning into the second week
where we will learn about the
application of genomics
in virology and also we will understand
from many case studies
and how you can apply this understanding
of genomics
by first doing literature review so we
will start from the
basic of research and we have a very
structured programs
that are leading to uh high value
research
so we have several examples of those and
many of
our interns who have joined are working
on research projects
using the same process so we start from
literature review
we will go through different
repositories that you will learn that
learn and you will find interesting
articles and that will be really
an amazing experience for those who are
interested in doing something new
a new research so finding out what has
been done
and how people have achieved those will
be some of the objectives of this
session
and how you can design a process and
design a project
using that information uh with the help
of experts
so this will be the first session after
the review
of the first week's activity so review
process and feedback process
is a very important and a very important
pillar in this
omics logic bioinformatics research
trainings
and especially genomics in the lab we
have sessions
or very intensive sessions like because
we have sessions every day
so we'll be expecting you to be endorsed
with all the experts and make the most
of this opportunity
so next session after learning about and
identifying
the research question we will be
learning about how you can you know
identify
viral species and strains and do
comparative analysis of viral genomes
understand the viral diversity and then
understand
how this is related how the mutations
are related to the
disease how it is related to the disease
pathology what are the phenotypic to
genotypic changes so how machine
learning and how
sorry how next generation sequencing is
playing a key role
in genomics for biology so that would be
the second session of the second week
after that we will learn about more
about the diversity of microbial
communities
so here we will learn about bacterial
genomes and then
we will learn about 16s rnas and we will
learn about
how metagenomics can can be applied to
study
directly samples that you can culture in
the lab
so that is such a big advantage that we
have with with the metagenomics
technology and you will be learning
about how metagenomics technology can be
applied
to answer many of those important
questions in this
difficult pandemic time where there is
so much of
a data is being generated related to
kobe 19.
so after that i mean once you have
applied
and learned about how genomics
metagenomics
plays a role in identifying
understanding
in the respect of uh in the respect of
finding these problems that you're
working on
on the aspect of project uh project and
all
so in this session we will learn about
the basic principles between
behind antiviral and active
antibacterial drug
and the approaches for vaccine design so
it's a very important topic
and this can be done like once you have
the holistic understanding and overview
of all of the topics that we covered
we come to this stage uh where we are
talking about antibodies and antiviral
drugs
so the earlier understanding is equally
important for you to come to this stage
and to make the most and understand the
translational value
of genomics
so the next session after that on
second july will be about hands-on
session uh analysis of genomics from
ncbi virus
so we will be going to ncvi virus we
will be
downloading the genomes and we'll be
using the t binfor server
to analyze those genomes so we also have
some of the
project examples that we have already
prepared for you for this program
that you will be utilizing and learning
from so those examples will also be
available
on the learn or mixed logic platform
that you have that you will have access
to and subscription to you throughout
this program
so uh after the completion of second
week
we will be working on the weekend
to develop these projects ideas into
presentations
so this is a first step to work towards
a
program so one of the practical outcome
of outcomes of this program
is that you get a feedback
from a renowned expert in the field of
genomics in the field of disease
research in the field of
all the other genomic application so we
here we have
renowned scientists from all around
india all around
from many around universities in the us
so you will have an expert panel to
discuss
uh about those project feed project
proposals that you will come up with
so one of the objectives as i was
telling you is to develop
an independent research project that
could be reviewed
in this entire process so after the
completion of this
two scheduled uh you know weeks so
the first phase is the first week by dr
sona the second phase
uh by omixlogic team on all of this that
you have seen
and the fourth and third and the fourth
week will be more about
uh research project so we will be
working with experts
and we will have group sessions and
one-on-one sessions
to develop a research project and that
requires a few steps
so i'll just quickly describe you those
steps so the first step
to a research project is to find a
problem right
first you have to find a problem uh and
then
you have to find very then you have to
be very specific
and be focused that that the problem
that you're interested in
so that that would be from you
you will be have you will have that
opportunity to come up with your own
research project
and also will have opportunity to work
on already prepared projects that are
available
so after doing that we will be doing the
literature review as i've already
told you and then we will do exploratory
analysis
where we will look into different data
sets and find those
insights from that data set so entire
process of
uh of uh working from
uh week to week will uh help us
develop some of those research projects
and i
think uh i'll also request sonalika to
maybe share
some of those completed research
projects with you here as well
so this is about the program and how we
are going to uh
go through this journey one month
journey research journey
and now uh i would like to maybe take
you to the registration process
and show you how you can register for
the program
so maybe i'll find the link in the chat
so sonic if you can paste the
registration okay it's here
that's the blog post
so once you have a login you will find
yourself
uh like this like a name and then
in this you'll have a profile so once
you log in you'll see like this
but if you have not login then uh
then i recommend you to create a free
login
on the learn platform on the run omix
logic and
start exploring many of the
opportunities that we bring you here
so genomics in the virtual lab you can
find it here
and then
[Music]
then you go in and then you start your
application so this is a free workshop
and if you want us to if you want
us to send you more emails and details
about the program
then you can request for more
information and submit your details
and as you have joined this program i
believe many of you have already
registered
so you have done your registration part
but now you have to finish your
registration by completing
and submitting the uh registration fees
so i'll go to the registration fees and
i'll describe you different
levels of uh levels that we have
for you to join and explore so beginners
level as i
showed you all of those uh things that
we will do has
all the features uh to complete this
course and get a certificate
and then we have the intermediate level
if you think that you need
additional sessions with one of us one
of the mentors
then you can opt for the intermediate
level so that will give you an option to
have
a couple of sessions with the mentor to
guide you
and give you an hands-on experience by
doing screen sharing and helping you
to go through the resources and all of
that and the tutorials
so if you require that level of that
level of support you can opt for
intermediate
and the third option is advanced advance
is for an additional
work to work additionally on your
project
so if you are working on a project and
if you already have a proposal ready
and you're working maybe with a lab or
you're working
with some university so you can opt for
an advanced license as well
so once you select a license and i'll go
here
then you have an option where you can
fill up about the details uh
your card details and how you are going
to submit the fee and at the same time
you can also add promotional codes
so these promotional codes are given up
as scholarships so we have given
a lot of scholarships to previous
participants before
who would want to join this program and
could not afford the full
price of this uh this logic program
so you can apply for scholarship and
i'll request an alikar again i'm so
sorry that i'll i have to request you
again and again but
uh please if you can share the
scholarship form as well
that would be great so uh yeah as i was
telling you that uh
with uh scholarships you can again do
this and if you're a bio clues
member then please reach out to bioclues
uh
bioclues members who are
available here and maybe any any of you
can share the email address to reach out
to and then
you will get a promotional quote from
bioclues and then you can apply that
biocues promotion code and get
uh get a scholarship from bioclues as
well
so i welcome you all to
complete this and join us for this uh
one month hands-on mentor guided
research training program
and if you have any questions and any
issues
feel free to reach out to us and we'll
be happy to
help you out with this so my email
address is movie.greatpine.bio
and uh i i think uh will share other
email addresses as well
so thank you i think i'll now look at
the questions and i'll pass it on to
sonalika for any other
questions that uh you may have
thank you so much dr mohan here in the
chat i have also shared the blog post
link with you all so that you can go
through what all would be covered all
the session details are mentioned there
as well
and also there are few of the sample
projects by some of our students from
the
previous genomics in the virtual lab
program and also i'll share the links of
those projects so that you can go watch
them and get the insights of how it is
done
what the outcomes are and how things
would work actually
and also i'll share this scholarship
form so the process is once you fill out
the scholarship
form you have to submit your cv and also
the references from your institution
we would be reviewing them and then we
would get back to you on that
and as sir has already mentioned the
registration form i'm also sharing the
link with you those who are interested
please register
so once we get your information we would
get back to you soon on that
and if you have any doubts uh please
mail us at mohit
pine dot bio or marketing at the pine
dot bio
and uh before we end this session i
would welcome you all to follow us on
linkedin as well following us there and
being a part of the group would help you
know about
all our upcoming programs and trainings
and also know about whatever courses we
update
it was nice to meet you all here thanks
for being a part of the webinar
if you have any doubts you you can reach
out to us and thank you so much
by a close team thank you so much dr
sona vasudevan for coming and sharing
such mind bog like mind boggling things
and it was a pleasure to have you here
thank you so much bye bye through steam
and thank you everyone for being here
now we'll meet in our next session
let's all meet there and discuss more
about the program and
begin with the program on 21st and uh
even now i am myself very very much
excited to be a part of the program
uh thank you so much we'll see
we'll see you all soon in the sessions
then bye bye take care